[موسيقى]
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات افكار الاستاذ والاستاذ طبعا هو
الدكتور جوده عبد الخالق الاستاذ الاقتصاد
المرموق والسياسي المصري المعروف والحقيقه
كان في حلقه بيننا مؤجره عن موضوع مفضل له
وهو الفقر ولكن احداث غزه اجلته كثيرا
السؤال بمنتهى البساطه اللي هته على معالي
الدكتور بعد ما اسلم عليه مساء الخيرات
معالي الدكتور مساء النور سيد نحن قد عدنا
الحمد لله على السلامه اهلا بم على
السلامه انا عندي سؤال بسيط واستاذن لو في
اجابه بسيطه لانه انتم
كاقتراح على المشاهد العادي السؤال هل
الفق فقر مسؤوليه
الفقير ام ان الفقر مسؤوليه
مصفوفه دوليه ومنظومه في الدوله بتلعب دور
كبير في افقار من هو فقير لا هو بالدرجه
الاولى ليس مسؤوليه الفقير يعني طبعا ممكن
نختلف في النسب لكن بالدرجه الاولى هو
مسؤوليه السياسات العامه ما يدير الش
العام بدليل تاريخيا لما نرجع
بالزمن الى
قبل ظهور الدوله الحديثه وتنظيم المجتمع
في مؤسسات وكلام من
ده مجتمع مقفول على نفسه خد مجتمع في
افريقيا مثلا او في غابات الامازون مش
هتلاقي يعني كل الناس ميه واحده ميه واحده
مصر في الستينات على سبيل المثال تقريبا
قريب من كده وبفضل السياسات العامه اللي
تطبقت لكن بالدرجه الاولى الفقر هو ناتج
عن يعني بفعل فعل خلينا اقول الفقر اللي
ما يبقى الشخص مسؤول
عنه يعني بمفعول القوى القاهره وليس بقرار
فردي بمعنى انه واحد ولد بعها او ولد
لاسره فقيره ممكن جدا وماقدرش يكسر الحاجز
انا ولدت اسره فقيره لكن قدرت تكسر الحاج
لكن مش كل الناس كده القاعده العامه انه
ما يقدرش فيبقى في عمليه توريث
الفقر منطقه بحاله اصابها زلزال او مثلا
منطقه دخلت في بوتقه اتون حرب كما هو حادث
في غزه عمليه افقار على نطاق كبير جدا ما
يحدث نتيجه ما يحدث في غزه الان بتواطئ
مجتمع دولي وفعل قوى غاشمه ومقاومه بطوليه
من الغزاويه والفلسطين واحد يرفع لهم
القبع اه طبعا وذلك ده بيخلينا
نقول وانت تصمم السياسه العامه هذا تمييز
مهم ليه لانه لو ان
لو ان الفقر ناتج عن الظروف التي تحيط
بالانسان خارج
ارادته فالحل هو اجراءات للحمايه
الاجتماعيه اما لو ان الفقر ناتج عن مفعول
السياسات العامه في الاجراء هو العداله
الاجتماعيه ممكن نوضح يعني ازاي دوله اولا
احنا لما بنتكلم على دوله بنتكلم واضح ان
هي في العالم لانه في العالم كله في
الثروات بت ددس في ايدين عدد محدود جدا
بينما بينتشر الفقر بدرجات في ارقام كبيره
حتى في اكثر الدول ديمقراطيه وحريه زي
الولايات المتحده وزي اوروبا الى اخره
طبعا بدرجات لما حضرتك بتقول ان الفقر
مسؤوليه السياسات العامه هل يمكن ان توضح
لنا ايه مثلا امثله على السياسات العامه
اللي بتكر الفقر عند الفقراء بخلي مثلا لو
ان السياسات العامه تهمل تهمل ا مجالات
حيويه بالنسبه
للانسان تحديدا التعليم والصحه ف بينتج عن
هذا انه في المجمل ما لا يستطيع تدبير هذه
الخدمات الحيويه ا بيبقى له ساقط المتاع
وفي هذه الحاله تكوينه من الناحيه
الصحيه الى حد ان قدراته العقليه بتتاثر
نتيجه لهذا بالذات في المراحل السنيه
الاولى وتعيش معاه بعد كده
وايضا نفس الشيء على التعليم ولذلك بنخس
التعليم والصحه في المصطلح الاقتصادي
بتعبير مهم جدا بنسميه السلع العامه السلع
العامه ببلك جودز ما معنى سلع عامه انت
ممكن تروح مثلا المحل تشتري سكر او ارز او
ملابس او سياره الى اخره ولكن
ا نفس الشيء لاينطبق بنفس الدرجه على
الصحه والتعليم واحد اثنين انه من خصائصها
انه الانفاق على الصحه والتعليم على الفرد
يعود بفيض كبير على المجتمع ككل
ا وبالتالي بنقول لها اثار خارجيه كبيره
ده معنى الس وبالتالي في الموجز لا يمكن
ا تحقيق توزيع كفء الموارد في مجال الصحه
والتعليم من خلال السوق وانما من خلال
المال العام هل تسلي ابسط الفكره دي فكره
جوهريه انا انا اذكر كمان ان صديقك
واستاذي الله يرحمه الدكتور عثمان محمد
عثمان رغم ان هو كان ميال جدا الى يعني
اقتصاد السوق وعنده مدرسه مختلفه يعني
ولكن كان يقول لي انا تعريفي للعداله
الاجتماعيه في حدها الادنى انك توفر تعليم
وصحه لكل المواطنين فقير وغني وتتاكد انه
هيكون عنده فرصه مفتوحه لسوق العمل مش حكر
على حد للتوضيح اللي حضتك بتقوله كثير من
الاقتصاديين بيقولوا انه اذا دوله ما لم
تتاكد ان الفقير قبل الغني قادر على ان
يحصل على رعايه صحيه جيده وتعليم جيد يبقى
بالضروره هيكون فقير صحيح لانه هيبقى معتل
الصحه وغير قادر انه يتملك قدرات تمكنه من
دخول سوق العمل ده اللي حضت عظيم ج ده رقم
واحد ده رقم واح رقم اين طبعا
الموضوع بيتش عب لانه يتج
مستوى السلع العامه مثل الصحه والتعليم
الى مستوى سياسات عامه في مجالات حاكمه
اخرى زي مثلا مجال توزيع الدخل توزيع
الدخل في العصر الحديث نظر لوجود حكومات
ومجالس تشريعيه
نيابيه في الغالب مصفوفه القوى السياسيه
في
المجتمع بتعمل فاصل بين ما تجود به
الطبيعه وعرق الانسان من خيرات ومنتجات
وبين ما يصب في جيوب الناس من دخل يعني
ادي مثال لو عندي فلاح مثلا بيزرع الارز
على سبيل المثال بيزرع الارز ارزه قيمه
معينه في السوق اذا تم من خلال تدخل
السلطه مثلا وزاره التموين او ايا كان انك
ترغم الفلاح على انه يقوم بتوريد
رزه الى السلطات سعر اقل من سعر السوق
فانت حرمته من ناتج عمله وبالتالي
ا
بتفق بهذا المعنى وافقار هنا لا يعود الى
مجهوده هو او تكاسل انما يعود الى سياسات
التوزيعيه العامه مثلا الضرايب على سبيل
لانه اللي هي ادوات اعاده التوزيع الضرائب
والاعانات ممكن جدا الضرائب تكون متحيزه
للفئات الاضعف في المجتمع
فتبقى تؤدي الى افقار اعداد متحيزه ضد
عفوا متحيزه ضد متحيزه ضد
ه متحيزه ضدهم او متحيزه الى الفئات الايه
الاكبر والاجنه حاز تخل ونفس الشيء
بالنسبه للاعانات يعني مثلا لو خدنا بند
الاعانات لوحده وقمنا بتحليله في بلاد
كثيره بنتكلم يعني مثلا انا عشت كاستاذ
زائر في الولايات المتحده خمس
مرات عبر مراحل تاريخي المهني كاستاذ
واعرف كويس قوي ان كيف انه في
توزيع الدعم من وجون مختلفه ا يعني الفتات
هو الذي يصل الى المحرومين و ندي مثال بقى
من الولايات بس الاعانات بتروح ازاي
للاغنياء الاعانه لا تذهب بالتعريف الى
الغني لا اقول لك دلوقتي ما الكونجرس
بناقش ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع كويس كده
و بسبب الحرب هنا وهناك سواء الفعليه او
المحتمله طبقا المخططات عايزين يوسعوا
قدرات وزاره الدفاع في مجال الحرب والضرب
ففي حاجه اسمها العقود التي تذهب الى هذه
الشركات عقود بمليارات
الدولارات و
تعني انه اصحاب هذه الشركات وهم ليسوا
العامه من الناس هم المستفيدون بالدرجه
الاولى من هذا الدعم ده واحد طبعا يمكن
كلامك اكتر لو في مجال الصحه
والتعليم الامر ليس بهذا السوق انما لما
تيجي في مجال الزراعه مثلا والدعم الذي
قدم المزارعين دعم في امريكا دعم سخي جدا
وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي بالمناسبه دعم سخي
ايضا بالنسبه للزراعه انما لما تنظر في
التفاصيل اما ان اقاليم معينه بتستا سر
بنصيب الاسد او ان شرائح اجتماعيه معينه
بتستا سر بنصيب الاسد وهذا يؤدي الى زياده
الفارق بين الفئات الاجتماعيه او الطبقات
انجاز التعبير انما في موضوع عقود الدفاع
اللي انا اشرت و موضوع مهم جدا قد لا
يلاحظ العامه من الناس هذا الامر وبالتالي
ماهواش داخل في دائره اهتمام المهتم هو
الدائره اللي بتتابع العقود وانما بما
بحكم المبالغ كلها وحكم انها رايحه لشريحه
من المحدوده من الشركات بتخلق درجه من
التفاوت وينتج عنها هو انا بس كان سؤالي
انه لا انا فهمت ده بس انا ده كده
الموازنه بصفه عامه لكن كلمه الاعانات
فهمت منها ان الاعانات يعني المساعدات فده
يدخل حرك بتتكلم على الموازنه كلها طبعا
لا هو انا اصته بكلمه اعانات يعني لو
بصينا الموازنه انها منه بتاخد من فئات
وتدي فئات تانيه ايوه بالضبط اذا كانت
بالتساوي بتاخد من الفئات المختلفه قدر ما
تقدمه لها يبقى هي محايده من ناحيه عداله
التوزيع احنا بنتكلم من اول الحلقه عن
السياسات العامه اللي بتكر الفقر فقلت اول
حاجه التعليم والصحه ابص لها الاني اين
رقم اثنين توزيع الدخول او السياسه
الماليه السياسه الماليه انا مين بياخذ
نصيب الاسد من موازنه الدوله وم سياستها
الاغنياء بيستفيدوا اكثر ولا الفقراء
ويدخل فيها الضرايب انا باخد الضرايب
الاكثر من مين من الاغنياء والفقراء عندي
رقم عاوز اعرضه على حضرتك بس قبل ما اقطع
حبل افكارك رقم لاثه في رقم لاثه اه في
رقم لاثه في سياسات الاستثمار الاستثمار
انت مثلا لما تيجي في منطقه وتستثمر في ما
يسمى البنيه الاساسيه طرق وكباري وما شابه
انت مباشره بتخلق قيمه جديده
للاصول المتداوله في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
اذا لم يواكب هذا الاجراء اللي هو تطوير
البنيه من خلال الاستثمار من المال العام
اذا ل يواكبه فرد ضرائب لاستعاده جزء من
ما انفق من المستفيد من هذا الانفاق يبقى
ده بيؤدي الى خلل واذا قلنا بتقول طب وعلا
بت بتؤدي الى اغتناء بعض الناس صح انما
ازاي تؤدي الى افكارهم حول باعتبار ان
الموازنه العامه للدوله هي الاداه
الرئيسيه او المركزيه كل ده بيصب فيها
فلما يميل او ينحرف الميزان لمحبات فئات
معينه بالض الضروره بيترك فئات اخرى في في
العراء فمثلا تجد ان الموارد لا تكفي ل
الانفاق على الصحه والتعليم بشكل كافي او
المعارض لا تكفي للاستثمار في البنيه
التحتيه في مناطق اخرى قد تكون يكون اكثر
استحقاقا احنا عندنا في مصر كان مثال واضح
وتعمدت عليه دراسات سابقه يعني في
انه ان انفق كتير جدا مثلا على الطرق
المؤديه للساحل الشمالي اللي بيستفيد من
الساحل الشمالي في الغالب ان لم يكن
بالضروره هم الطبقه المتوسطه والغنيه في
الوقت اللي كانت في الانفاق على البنيه
التحتيه في الارياف والاقاليم كان اقل
بكتير فاكيد ده ادى الى اثراء ناس باعت
وحدات واشترت وحدات انا فاهم غلط بالضبط
كده على حساب الموازنه المحدوده اللي لن
تذهب طالما انفقت هنا لن اعجز سوف اعجز
على الانفاق فيح عشان كده يعني من الورد
في حاله مصر كنا نتكلم انه بنقسم مصر
تاريخيا الى بحري والصعيد ريف وحضر وانا
بقدر اح تسميه مستجده اهل الساحل واهل
الداخل اهل الساحل واهل
الداخل احيانا اهل الساحل بيملكه كتير من
اللي في الداخل برض طبعا
رقم عه رقم
عه السياسات اذا تدخلت الدوله بالتسعير
سواء بتسعير عناصر الانتاج يعني العمل او
بتسعير المنتجات يعني القطن او الارز او
سلع اخرى فهذه العمليه قد يترتب
عليها اعاده توزيع الدخل لصالح فئات و على
حساب فئات اخرى وبالتالي خلق ف هنا ما لو
نشاط الدوله
في التسعير الاداري خلينا نسميه وليس جبري
تسعير الاداري يطلع قرار من الوزير انت
سلم المحص من القطن بسعر كذا سلم الارز
بسعر كذا في هذه الحاله طبعا ده يعني
ماهواش جزء من السياسه الماليه مباشره
وليس جزء من سياسه
الاستثمار وليس جزء من الانفاق على سلع
عامه انما يصب اساسا في عمليه التسعير ان
تاخد عنصر العمل مثلا وتسعير العمل خصوصا
اذا كنت بتتبع قاعدتين مختلف مساله مهمه
جدا تيجي في تسعير المنتجات تقول انا هاخد
بالسير العالمي خيص وتيجي في تسعير العمل
العاده للعمل تقوللك والله عندنا ظروف
محليه فينتج عن هذا لو خ ايوه لا الامثله
واضحه جدا انا
كاستاذ
جامعي ممكن ابيع خدماتي
كاقتراح والعائد اللي هيحصل عليه اضعاف
اضعاف اضعاف العائد اللي حصل عليه حاليا
طيب انا رضيت بهذا كمواطن مصري مافيش
مشكله ولكن اللي يجوز تيجي تقوللي انا
هقدم لك الكهرباء بالسير العالمي ودين
المرتب بسعر مظبوط طبعا
ععر مدعوم بالاجبار مظبوط مظبوط والله انا
كنت مره قريت ملحوظه لا انساها في بريد
القراء في احد الجرايد لما كان في جرايد
كان في جرا طيب كان في مصر داير يعني احد
المسؤولين واحيانا بعض المسؤولين الحقيقه
بيكونوا غير موفقين في الكلام بيقول لك
احنا احنا بندعم الدوله بتصرف كانه هو
بيجيب من جيبه الكلام ده في مصر وفي غيرها
يعني بس انا بتكلم كان على مثل مصري احنا
بندعم بكذا وبنب عنكم بكذا يعني كانه
بيتفل عليه ففي قارئ لا انسى تعليقه قال
مين بيدعم مين انت عندك طبيب بيشتغل مش
عارف 250 ولا ايه وظابط بيشتغل ب 1000 كذا
ارقام صغيره جدا للرواتب
فعاوز يقول له انه فكره حضرتك ان اللي
بيشتغل بالاجور المنخفضه دي هي من تدعم
اجهزه الدوله في حقيقه المبو مش كده وربط
هذا بموضوع الفقر نتكلم على فئات معينه
مثل الاطباء يعني ملاحظ حاليا انه معدلات
نزوح الاطباء المص ما يسمى هجره الاطباء
الى خارج مصر عاليه الى الحد ان بعض
الخبراء في الصحه العامه والصحه عموما
حذروا من هذا الاتجاه ا معنى هذا الكلام
انه بعد ما كان عندي طبيب في الوحده
المحليه في القريه انفجا هذا الطبيب لم
يعد موجود وبالتالي الخدمات التي تقدم
للمواطنين في هذا النطاق الجغرافي المحدود
وهم عاده عاده من البسطاء ومحدود الدخل
بيتاثر وبالتالي في في دوره ثانيه لهذه
العمليه الجهنميه في عمليه افقار من ناحيه
انك انت علمت الطبيب من المال العام
وهنيجي نشوف المال العام ده جه من نجيب
مين بالضبط وباي نسب وبعدين لما خرج نقلت
الاستثمار ده كله الى مجتمع الخارج
لكن المردود بتاعه على المجتمع المحلي
سلبي في هذه الحاله اذا في جوهر هجره
العقول خصوصا من الدول الناميه هو الخلل
اللي حضرتك اشرت اليه انه عنده هو بيعيش
عيشه عيسه احد اسبابها ان الاسعار محرره
لانها بالسعر العالمي تقريبا يعني او هكذا
تصب الحكومات بينما الاجور ليست هاجسه
الجور الاجور مضغوطه عاز اسال حجه ممكن
اقول ملاحظه وليس المقصود بها اتصالا وليس
المقصود بيا ان انا بعمل دعايه لنفسي اه
لا اتفضل انا قبل ما انهي اناقش رساله
الدكتوراه بتاعتي في كندا فجئت بالقسم
الاقتصاد بيعرض عليا ان انا اشتغل استاذ
وده استثناء جامد جدا ما فيش جامعه بتعين
الخريج بتاعها استاذ اه انما لسب هم
شايفين قاللي قلت لهم طب ه تدوني كام
قالوا 3000 دولار ده وقتها كان جميل انا
كنت وقتها لما ارجع مصر اخد ما يعادل 100
دولار وخلي بالك من النسبه
والتناسب كم ضعف دي 30 ضعف احسبها بقى
انما المهم كان
ليا حساب اخر بمعايير اخرى ان انا اصلا جو
عبد الخالق عشان اوصل لمرحله ان اعمل
الكراع ده مش مجهودي ولا حاجه انما على
حساب الغلابه اللي في 100 العز وغيرها من
المناطق الرف دول في الواقع اللي بيعرق
ويكد شايلين المجتمع فانا لا يستقيم
اخلاقيا معايا ان انا اقعد واخد هذا
المرتب العالي واسيب اولاد الغلاب اللي
انا طلعت منهم وبفضلهم ان نعمل لكن ده
طبعا حساب مالوش علاقه بالاقتصاد عارف
انما الحساب الاقتصادي عشان تستقيم الامور
في المجمل لابد من وجود علاقه علاقه
متوازنه بين الجهد والعائد على ال عشان
كده مفهوم العداله الاجتماعيه بيفرض نفسه
في هذا
السياق
لاتقاء خطر انتشار الفقر على نطاق واسع في
المجتمعات انا بقدر ما انا مستمتع بهذه
النقاط بس انا الان ان يكون جزء من
متابعينا من غير الخلفيه الاقتصاديه فيكون
الكلام صعب عليه فمحال السؤال انا عاوز
اسال حضرتك ببساطه اولا حضرتك قلت انا قبل
ما اسال السؤال البسيط مضطر على على
حاجتين لما بتقول مصفوفه السلطه ماذا تقصد
بكلمه مصفوفه السلطه علماء السياسه
يتحدثون عن ان السلطه
ا كاحد اهم ا ادوات اداره الشان العام في
المجتمعات ان خيرا فخير وان شرا فشر على
حسب توجه السلطه هذه المصفوفه باختصار
معناها درجه تمثيل القوى الاجتماعيه
المختلفه على مستوى السلطه واتخاذ القرار
فاذا كانوا كلهم مثلا من الطبقه المتوسطه
ومن الطبقه العليا اكيد هتكون انحيازاته
لهذه الطبقه بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني مثلا
تتكلم على الكونجرس خلي بالك ما تاخذ نطبع
الحاله
الامريكيه في الحاله الامريكيه نظامهم
السياسي بيسمح في الواقع
بمساله التبرع بمبالغ سخيه جدا للحملات
الانتخابيه الانتخابيه سواء لاعضاء مجلس
النواب او مجلس الشيوخ يعني الكونجرس
وايضا ال منصب الرئيس وبالتالي هنا
اللي ثل ممثليه ليس العوامل من الشعب في
الواقع اه طبعا ده المقصود ب مصفوفه
السلطه وطبعا مصفوفه السلطه يعني من اتى
بمن يحكم الى السلطه هو اللي بيتحكم في
المساله صحيح وبتقول اولوياتهم هي
ارضاء هؤلاء الاثرياء يعني انت لما حضتك
بتقول لازم يكون في علاقه بين الجهد
والعائد ايوه ما هو ده حضرك طرحتها مره مع
وانا ما فهمتهاش اثنين مدرسين اثنين
محامين ده عنده ثروه لانه عنده جهد وعنده
براعه وعنده كذا واحداني اقل منه فهو لا
يحصل على نفس العائد مش ده اللي انت تقصده
لا لا لان ده ده هو في الواقع من قبيل
استثناء اللي هو التفاوت الكبير في
القدرات من شخص الى اخر اتكلم على القاعده
العامه اللي بالتاكيد للا استثناه انه في
القاعده العامه قدرات الناس متقاربه
متقاربه
وبالتالي وبيظل مجهود متقارب برض كقاعده
عامه وبالتالي
المفترض ان
تتناسب
المكافات مع الجهد الايه الجهد المبذول ده
ما بيحصلش ناخد مثال
ا مثلا خد عمال مناجم في بعض البلاد ما
ينتجونه شديد الاهميه بالنسبه
للمجتمع بيتعرض موجات من البرد القارص جدا
و اخره مبوط ولا وظروف
عملهم شديده الصعوبه كما نعلم جميعا بتكلم
هنا على المناجم تحت الارض في ظروف
وتعرضوا لمخاطر ج ومع ذلك بقرار من السلطه
يقول لك انت تشتغل وبهذا المعدل فقط فانت
حرمت هذا الشخص في الوقت اللي المجتمع بيث
منن ما يحصل عليه ا من من خيرات يعني من
خيرات ا مضبوط ا وحرمته ده حصل مثلا ادي
مثال ب انجلترا ايام فتره مرج تاتشر لما
فرضت على عمال المناجم ان هم يشتغلوا
بالاجور دي وانتهى الامر بحل جزء كبير من
نقابات العمال فهنا بقى حل نقابات العمال
مع انها بتعيد تشكيل مصفوفه السلطه في
المجتمع انا عندي رقم يعني رقمين مخيفين
يمكن يعني اكدوا كلام حضرتك بس ممكن يعني
ايه لو تعليق حضرتك عليهم حتى كان في
مقاله حبيت اشاركها مع حضرتك انه كان لا
اذكر اسم الكاتب كان كاتب في فورن بولسي
عن السر
القدر السر القذر ده اللي بيشير اليه هو
انتشار ظاهره التهرب من الضرائب وبيتكلم
على الدول الديمقراطيه الكبيره الغنيه غير
طبعا الدول الفقيره يعني وقال انه يكاد
يكون امر شائع جدا ان الشركات الكبيره ان
كبار الاثرياء بيتخفف من الجزء الاكبر مما
يجب ان يدفعوه من ضرائب من
خلال منظومه كده التهرب من الضرائب وجنات
الضرائب المعروفه والبعض قدر هذه الاموال
بحوالي 50 ترليون دولار قد يكون الرقم
مبالغ فيه قد يكون قليل لكن رقم ضخم جدا
هذا واحد اثنين سنويا بتصدر تقديرات لما
يملكه اغنياء العالم مقارنه بما يملكه
فقراء العالم واحده من المؤسسات دي وهم
كثير اكس فام فبتقول مثلا ان في 2023 20
فقط 1% من البشر يملكوا 50% من ثروات
العالم بينما افقر 50% من الكره الارضيه
كلها بيملك اقل من 1% من ثروات العالم عند
حرك التعليق الاول على الا ا عشان بس اللي
بيتابع انا يعني يعرف احنا بنتكلم عن ايه
ما تتحدث
عنه منظمه اوكس فم هو كلام محترم جدا مبني
على دراسات جاده يكلم ليس عن الدخل انما
عن الثروه وطبعا توزيع الثروه
اكثر
تباينا من توزيع الدخل بشكل عام في
المجتمعات المختلفه ان معنى الكلام دي
ظاهره مسميها لما تيجي اوكسفام تقول لك ما
يملكه هذا العدد من الاغنياء يعادل نصف ما
يملكه باقي المجتمع دي ظهرين بتسميه ظاهره
الهرم المقلوب زهه الهرم المقلوب الطبيعي
في حاله الهرم العادي اللي زي ما بنشوفه
خفر
خوف منقرع القاعده واسعه والقمه ضيئ
وبالتالي بيضمن لهذا الكيان الاتزان صح ا
انما لما تيجي تجد لاسباب متعدده تحدثنا
فيها القمه اصبحت اكثر اتساعا من
القاعده يبقى مباشره ده معناه
انه بذور عدم الاتزان وبالتالي
القلاقل ب تبقى غرست في التربه الاجتماعيه
طيب معنى الكلام ده ايه بقى انك انت تفسر
حواليك انتشار ظاهره العنف والصراعات التي
تندل في مجتمعات كثيره جدا في العالم وده
بالمنا عاي اشيل الكتاب لسه
مخلصه يعني من ايام الكتاب عنوانه جذور
الغضب زمن الغضب يا دكتور كويس الكاتب
الحقيقه بيحاول يوصل للجذور
خلقت الغضب الغضب هنا اللي هو قد ينفجر في
شكل قلاق الاجتماعيه اضطرابات اعمال عنف
فرديه اعمال عنف حتى منظمه ا فهو عنده
طيمه ممكن تواف نا بيقول انه في الواقع في
القرن
19 من خلال الفكر السياسي والاجتماعي
الغربي وعدوا وعدوا الناس العاديين بالجنه
ازاي من خلال اقتصاد السوق
وحريه الحركه للمنشات الفرديه والدوله
تتراجع الى الوراء لا تتدخل وتترك الامور
يعني كما قال ادم سميث مقولاته المشهوره
دعه يعمل دعه يمر لسفر لس مافيش تدخل
الدوله الا في اضيق الحدود
هذا في
الواقع كان خطا كبير في التصور والناس
اللي صدقت هذا السياق وسارت في هذا الطريق
بدات تكتشف انه الواقع غير ذلك وبالتالي
بدا تنتج نزعات من العنف احتجاجا على هذا
الوضع الاجتماعي اللي هم وثقوا فيه
وتصوروا انه حقدهم الى الجنه الايه الجنه
المض فدي نقطه اللي هو مفعول الفكر والفكر
على فكره تاثيره هام جدا طبعا وكل حاجه بت
تضفها لذا المشهد العام ونح نتحدث عن
التفاوت والفقر والعداله الا
طيب يعني انا طبعا اقدر افهم من كلام
حضرتك وده مش محتاج استنتاج انا حضرتك
بتقول ان ان السبب الرئيسي ل السبب
الرئيسي يعني للخلل اللي موجود هو النظام
الاقتصادي اللي بيسيطر على العالم واللي
بيادي الى ظاهره الهرم المقلوب انه عدد
محدود جدا بيملك معظم ثروات العالم
بالمناسبه انا عندي رقم ثاني في 2023 حتى
مارس حوالي
2600 ملياردير في العالم حوالي 2600 ده
بيملك اكتر من 12 ترليون دولار لوحدهم
يعني فارقام مخيفه جدا انما حرك بتقول ان
النظام القائم
هو السبب الرئيسي لانه هذا النظام قائم
بالدرجه الاولى على انه يترك حريه السوق
بلا انضباط بلا انضباط واد ده الى
توحش يعني توحش في السياس طبعا سيد لو كان
الامر عن استحقاق فاهلا به وسهلا لانه
استحقاق معناها بيصب في المصلحه العامه ان
هو ليس كذلك نتيجه ا هيمنه غير متوازنه
على السلطه وانا اتذكر بالمناسبه
ا حينما اندلعت ثوره يناير
في
2011 وصلت اضاعها الى قلب صناعه المال في
العالم في نيويورك وطلعت مجموعه
هناك بتنادي بنفس ما نادىه الثوار في
ميدان التح حرير عيش حريه عداله اجتماعيه
وكان احتجاجهم اساسا على انه من يحصل على
الجزء الاكبر من الكعكه في امريكا هم
بارونات المال في وول ستريت اه طبعا وهذا
غير مقبول لانه كل الناس تحصل على اكثر
مما يستحقون معنا ان هناك اخرون سيحصلون
على اقل مما
يستحقون دول عموا بقسوه شديده جدا ثوار
وول ستريت فاكر طبعا عموا بطريقه قاسيه
جدا وعا اسال حضرتك سؤال اخير
ا هو حضرتك دايما بتتكلم ان النظام القائم
ده اللي هو النظام السوق ا الحر بشكل
منفلت هو هو السبب الرئيسي في تكريس الفقر
وان الفقراء ليسوا مسؤولين في معظم
الاحيان عن فقرهم وحرك شرحت ده عندي
ا سؤالين سؤال لانه هيكون اكاديمي فا
استذكرت قبل السوق الحر هو كان في نظام
بديل يعني هو السوق نظام السوق يعني ادم
السمت ما اخترع ش حاجه هو جاء اقر اذا كان
في اجابه بسيطه ما كانش ممكن نخليها حلقه
تانيه لا هو طبعا هنا مرتبط بتطور ما
نسميه النظم الاقتصاديه كويس فانت بتتكلم
حاليا على نظام الرئيس المالي يعني اللي
هوه ده اللي بتكلم عليه هو كل حاجه انما
قبل نظام الرئيس المالي كان في محطه ثانيه
ق البشريه على صعيد النظم الاقتصاديه كان
يسمى النظام الاقطاعي ونظام قائم ب على
اساس انه الزراعه وبالتالي الارض هي
المقاومات الاساسيه لحياه نظام استعباد من
جانب ملاك الارض لمن يعملون عليها في ظل
ما يسمى
ا نظام القنانه القنانه من قن والقن اللي
هو عبد الارض فالارض يعتبر عفوا العامل
على الارض يعتبر تابع لملك الارض تنتقل
ملكيه الارض الى سيد اخر ينتقل معها ملكيه
الشخص الاد هذا الوضع طبعا ا استدعى ثورات
وقلاقل كبيره جدا للانتقال في ظل هذا
النظام كان نظام الاقطاع اقطاع لم تكن ما
يسمى السوق الحر السوق الحر لها مصفات لكي
تنطلق لم تكن متوفره كل ضيعه بتعمل
على اشباع حاجات سكانها طبعا بالدرجه
الاولى للسيد واتباعه وبدرجه الثانيه
القائم انما في كل الاحوال ده كله ضيع لما
ازلت هذه الحواجز عملت النقله من النظام
الاقطاعي الى النظام الراسمالي اصبح
الاليه الاساسيه الحاكمه هي اليه السوق ان
كل شيء يخضع لمفعول العرض والطلب طيب
معروف ان السوق اشبه
بالحصان الجامع فليس من الحكمه انك انت
تركب حصان جامع بلا سرج وبلا لجام وهذا هو
المقصود بنظام السوق المنفلت ا انما في
المجتمعات اشرنا منذ قليل الى مجتمع
اسكندنافيا لا بتتكلم وكذلك المانيا
بتتكلم عن نزوم السوق الاجتماعي هوده كان
سؤال الثاني اتفضل كمل فض كنت اقوللك على
على مثال لسوق تعتقد انه متوازن وممكن
نحاول ان احنا نصبه اليه او هو في
الولايات المتحده
وشيعها الايه الاسواق فوق الانسان كويس
كده في دول السوق الاجتماعي
ومنها قديم
المانيا واسكن وحديثا الصين
بالمناسبه بيقوللك الانسان فوق الاسواق
انا ادير الاسواق بما يخدم الانسان ولا
اطوع الانسان لخدمه الايه ده الفرق
الجوهري ذلك في في سياق الجدل السياسي
الدائر في منطقتنا من العالم الكلام على
خصخصه وتحويل ملكيه العامه الى خاص هذا
الموضوع
حتى
نديره باقل قدر من الخسائر والمخاطر
الاجتماعيه يتطلب
اداره حازمه وقادره من السلطه
المركزيه اللي هو كيف تدير ذلك في بند
كبير جدا من بنود الجدل تحت عنوان تنظيم
الاسواق
وبالمناسبه جائزه نوبل في الاقتصاد منحت
اكثر من مره لاكثر من
اقتصادي
تقديرا لا اضاءات في موضوع تنظيم الاسواق
ودي قضيه حرقه جدا كيف تنظم الاسواق بما
يؤدي
الى تحقيق اكبر مكسب لاكبر عدد من الناس و
يبقى الضرر في اقل القليل وعلى شريحه ضيقه
من الناس تنظيم الاسواق جزيل الشكر مع
الدكتور اهلا ب ربنا يخليك ويسعدك ون
القاك في حلقات اخرى باذن الله باذن الله